Noora had been to see her aunt who was
expecting a baby she was curious to know
whether it would be a baby boy or a baby
girl but how can this be found how is
the sex of a child determined and is it
the same for other animals as well let's
find out sex determination is carried
out in various types the two major types
that we will focus on are the genotypic
sex determination and the environmental
sex determination let's begin with the
first type that is the genotypic method
in this type the sex of a child is
determined by the sex chromosomes we
know what sex chromosomes are in humans
for example the last pair is the sex
chromosomes
while the first 22 pairs are called
autosomes similarly in many other
organisms the sex chromosomes help to
decide the sex of an individual let's
take an example of mammals in most of
them including humans the sex of a child
is determined by the sex chromosomes
namely x and y we note that in humans
individuals with both x chromosomes are
females while those with 1 X and one Y
are males this is one type of genotypic
sex determination now let's take the
case of birds it is similar to the case
of humans but only that their system is
reversed in the case of birds the
females have two different sex
chromosomes while males have both
similar chromosomes we use the letters Z
and W to represent the chromosomes in
them these letters are used just in
order to avoid any confusion with our
human chromosomes so a female is the one
with ZW and a male is the one with Z Zed
set of sex chromosomes
so the sex of the birds offspring is
dependent on females if the mother gives
her Zeit chromosome then it will be a
male with Zed Zed chromosomes while if
the mother gives a w chromosome then it
will be a female with ZW chromosomes so
just like in the case of humans in birds
as well the sex of the offspring is
determined by the sex chromosomes wasn't
this interesting now let's understand
the other types of genotypic sex
determination in the upcoming part
humans and birds have an amazing
genotypic sex determination method the
presence of a different sex chromosome
plays the vital role in determining the
sex of the offsprings now let's discuss
the third type of genotypic sex
determination in this case just like
humans here we have the sex chromosomes
x and y but the presence of a Y
chromosome has got nothing to do with
the sex of the child
in fact the sex chromosomes are not the
only factors instrumental in deciding
the sex of the child it is the ratio of
the sex chromosomes to the autosomes
that decides the offspring to be a male
or a female and which organisms exhibit
this pattern of sex determination one
example is the common fruit fly or the
Drosophila melanogaster but what exactly
is this ratio system it's the ratio of
sex chromosomes to the autosomes that
determine the sex of the offsprings an
example when a fly has two x chromosomes
and two sets of autosomes then the ratio
of taint will be 2 is to 2 which is 1
the flies with this ratio of 1 are
females a fly with the ratio of 0.5 is
male so in case the fly has one X and
one Y and two sets of autosomes
then the ratio will be 1 is to 2 making
the fly a male now tell me what if a fly
has 3 sex chromosomes x XY and two sets
of autosomes will it be a male or a
female give it a shot let's crack this
together if we calculate
actly then there are two x chromosomes
and two sets of autosomes does the ratio
obtained is 2 esta - that's one so this
fly will be a female the presence of the
Y chromosome does not affect the sex of
this fly it's the ratio of the X
chromosomes to the autosomes that
determines the sex
now let's talk about one more
interesting type of sex determination
that makes use of genes this system is
called the haploid diploid system can
you guess what the system could be well
let me help you the haploid diploid
system is the one in which the males are
haploid as they develop from
unfertilized eggs and females are
diploid as they develop from fertilized
eggs this system in which males are
haploid and females are diploid is
called the haploid diploid system this
system is predominantly found in the
lower members of the animal kingdom like
insects bees wasps and ants exhibit HAP
loda ploidy
there are a few more types of genotypic
sex determination prevailing in nature
but for now we will deviate towards the
next type of sex determination which is
environmental sex determination let's
learn about that in the next part what
will happen to water if kept at 0 degree
Celsius or at 100 degrees Celsius at 0
degrees the water will freeze to form
ice while at 100 degrees it will start
to boil but do you think temperature
effects only nonliving objects nope it
has a huge impact on the life of living
beings as well apart from regulating
various body systems it has a huge
influence on several important processes
of nature take sex determination for
example in certain animals the sex of
the offsprings is dependent on the
temperature at which the eggs are
incubated we note that sex determination
occurs in two major ways one is
genotypic sex determination and the
second is environmental sex
determination so temperature dependent
sex determination is a type of the
latter form let's look at this type in
detail to begin with
the sex of the offspring in some animals
is dependent on environmental factors
the first type is temperature dependent
sex determination in some reptiles like
crocodiles and alligators the sex of the
offspring depends on the temperature at
which the eggs incubate if the
temperature is high then the offspring
is female while if it's a low
temperature then the offspring is a male
same is the case for certain turtle
species if their eggs are incubated
above 32 degrees Celsius then all
develop as females while if incubated
below 28 degrees Celsius then all
develop as males
apart from temperature dependency what
other environmental factors determine
the sex of an offspring
well location is one thing yes you heard
me right but location of what to
understand this let's take the example
of the green spoon worm there are two
possibilities where these free-floating
larvae can land if the larvae land on
the bare ocean floor then they turn out
to be females and on the other hand if
they land on the body of a female then
that makes the larvae turn into a male
this is how location helps determine the
larvae sex is in this type of sex
determination interesting to revise in a
nutshell the sex of offsprings in
various animals is determined by two
major types one is the genotypic method
and the other is using environmental
factors the genotypic method involves
the sex chromosomes that determine the
sex of the offsprings just like the XX
and the XY system in humans or the Z Z
and the ZW system found in birds another
type in this category is the ratio of
sex chromosomes to the autosomes which
is seen in lower animals like Drosophila
melanogaster the second type of sex
domination system is the environmental
system animals like crocodiles
alligators and turtles exhibit the
temperature-dependent sex determination
while lower animals like the green spoon
world exhibit the location dependent sex
determination sit this was about the sex
determination system found in various
organisms to know more fascinating
things in genetics tune into our
upcoming videos and do not forget to
subscribe to our channel to receive more
interesting videos
[Music]